c'est un des premiers crimes de guerre
de la Russie dans sa guerre contre
l'Ukraine commençait en fait il y a 8
ans le vol mh17 de la malégénère lines
reliant Amsterdam et Kuala Lumpur est
abattu au-dessus du gambas par un
missile book russe
crime de guerre majeure puisque 298
passagers de plusieurs pays sont morts
dont la plupart était originaire des
Pays-Bas
c'est pour ça que le procès ouvert en
2020 s'est tenu dans ce pays regarde
coupable de l'écrasement intentionnelle
illégale de l'avion et meurtre
igorkin colonel du FSB les services
secrets russes soi-disant ministre de la
défense de la République populaire
séparatiste de donies qu'à l'époque avec
son collègue du FSB Sergueï d'obinski et
l'ukrainien Léonie karchenko ils sont
accusés d'avoir importé de Russie le
lance-missile book et donnez l'ordre
d'abattre ce qu'il croyait être un avion
de guerre ukrainien le quatrième accusé
est acquitté Moscou Annie toute
responsabilité est ni encore après avoir
exposé à grand frais 4 versions
différentes et je me souviens à l'époque
j'intervenais déjà dans les plateaux et
j'avais beaucoup de difficultés à
expliquer en une minute pourquoi telle
ou telle argument était faux c'est
vraiment un exercice qui est difficile
il y a un radar d'un côté il y a le
missile de l'autre c'est 6,10 personnes
qui vont travailler ensemble l'expert en
aéronautique Xavier titlemmann suit
l'affaire depuis le premier jour et il
parle d'une enquête impeccable en dépit
des obstructions russes au fur et à
mesure que la Russie s'enfonçait dans
ses mensonges on avait déjà dès le début
la capacité d'identifier quel type de
missile avait tiré parce qu'on avait des
morceaux de celui-ci des fragments on
avait également des photos et dizaines
de journalistes et de soldats et de
également des citoyens ukrainiens ont vu
passer le porteur du missile sur lequel
il manquait le missile sur le toit
l'enquête extrêmement minutieuse et
impliquer les familles des victimes à
toutes les étapes et à produits un
rapport qui est catégorique seul un
missile book a pu faire ce genre de
dégâts près du cockpit et les débris ont
même permis d'identifier de quelle
missile exactement il s'agissait et sa
provenance c'est vraiment pour moi une
des enquêtes les mieux faites que j'ai
pu observer par contre le fait que ces
coupables se retrouvent jamais derrière
les barreaux d'une prison ça je pense
que personne ne peut s'en satisfaire
pour les familles des disparues les
coupables directs sont condamnés mais
les vrais responsables sont ceux qui ont
déclaré
passagers du vol mh17 c'est l'agression
russe en Ukraine on veut la fin de cette
guerre l'enquête est le procès du volley
H17 resteront comme un modèle pour les
crimes de guerre qui ne manqueront pas
d'être recensés à la fin du conflit
ukrainien quel que soit son issue
Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Montréal